Since debuting in 2017, Riverdale has pushed
the boundaries of network television by placing
the familiar and formerly innocuous characters
of Archie Comics into increasingly outlandish
plots.
Season 4 is set to premiere in the fall of
2019, and we've got everything you need to
know.
The first season of Riverdale hit the CW as
a midseason addition in January 2017.
That first short set of 13 episodes proved
so popular that the CW brought the show back
as quickly as possible, promoting it to a
fall debut for season number two with a full
order of 22 episodes.
Beginning with season two and into season
three, Riverdale led off the CW's Wednesday
night programming, airing at 8 p.m.
That's not broken, so the network isn't going
to fix it: Riverdale will continue on its
fourth season with that same Wednesdays at
8:00 time slot.
On June 17, 2019, the official Riverdale Instagram
page gave fans the exact date when the show
would return: October 9th.
It will serve as the lead in to a similar
"old concept, new approach" mystery show:
Nancy Drew.
On March 4th, 2019, Riverdale cast member
Luke Perry died suddenly at the age of 52,
shortly after suffering a stroke.
The first episode to air after the passing
of the actor, who played Archie's sweet father
Fred Andrews, came with a title card reading,
"In Memoriam: Luke Perry, 1966–2019."
The final installment to feature Perry as
Andrews debuted in late April, with the actor's
final scene being a one-on-one with Archie,
offering his boy words of guidance and encouragement.
Riverdale writers didn't explicitly deal with
the fate of Fred in season three, but will
in season four.
On June 19th, 2019, showrunner Roberto Aguirre-Sacasa
tweeted out the title page of the script for
the first episode of season four, and it's
titled "Chapter Fifty-Eight: In Memoriam."
"Probably the most important episode of Riverdale
we'll do this year, if not ever.
A tribute to our fallen friend.
Thankful for this opportunity to honor Luke
& Fred."
This heavily implies that the Fred Andrews
character will be laid to rest.
At San Diego Comic-Con 2019, Aguirre-Sacasa
announced that the episode would feature a
special guest star: Shannen Doherty, Perry's
iconic screen partner from their "Dylan and
Brenda" days on Beverly Hills, 90210.
Apart from the tragic loss of Luke Perry as
Fred Andrews, the main cast of Riverdale will
all be back for season four.
The series will also welcome some high-profile
guest stars, both familiar and brand-new.
Archie's parents are divorced, and his mother
lived far away, so Molly Ringwald only appeared
occasionally as Mary Andrews.
With the loss of Perry, Ringwald will likely
up her involvement.
Aguirre-Sacasa told TV Line in May of 2019,
"We've talked about Molly having a bigger
presence next year to help her son."
Chad Michael Murray will also return as Edgar
Evernever, the creepy yet charming leader
of the Farm, the bizarre, organ-harvesting
cult that tore Betty's family apart.
And on that subject, Wyatt Nash is set for
a recurring arc as Charles Smith, an FBI agent
who also happens to be Betty's long-lost brother.
At Riverdale High, teen TV veteran Kerr Smith
will play tough new school principal Mr. Honey.
Sam Witwer, best known for his roles as Mr.
Hyde on Once Upon a Time and Agent Liberty
on Supergirl, will join the show as a troubled
writing teacher who becomes a mentor figure
for Jughead when the crown-wearing kid ships
off to a fancy prep school.
The fourth season of Riverdale will also mark
its characters' fourth year at Riverdale High.
Senior year is an important time for so many
teenagers, and it will be for Archie and the
gang, too.
It figures so large in their lives that regular,
normal high school stuff will take prominence
in the action of Riverdale's upcoming episodes.
Camila Mendes, who plays Veronica, told Entertainment
Weekly at Comic-Con,
"Season four is definitely senior year, high
school-focused, more about relationships and
those dynamics."
Meanwhile, Jughead's time away from Riverdale
could prove problematic for his relationship
with Betty, according to actor Cole Sprouse,
who told Entertainment Tonight,
"[Jughead's] only back in Riverdale on the
weekends.
I think that is going to inevitably put stress
on the relationship between Betty and Jughead.
I think it might be a little bit tense.
They might fall, turn away from each other,
only to come back together way stronger."
But will teen drama supplant pitch-black plots
like the Black Hood's killing spree, or Archie's
involvement in a deadly underground boxing
ring?
"You're doin' great, Arch."
"How many of these guys am I fighting?!"
Not quite.
Mendes added that Riverdale will certainly
explore "the mystery of what we saw at the
end of season three": a bleak flash-forward
depicting a blood-soaked Archie, Betty, and
Veronica.
Lili Reinhart, who plays Betty, also promises
that early in Season 4, the show will introduce
another major mystery.
Riverdale can't always be about mystery-solving
teens in grave danger.
Every so often, the series breaks the tension
with a fun high-concept episode.
A 2018 installment flashed back to Riverdale
High twenty-something years ago, centering
on the antics of the present-day adults of
Riverdale when they were teens, and portrayed
by the show's young cast members.
A few months later, a meta, self-referential
episode found Riverdale High's drama club
staging a musical production of the high school
cult classic Heathers.
"Now how in God's name is a play about teen
violence and suicide a good idea in Riverdale?"
Riverdale Season 4 will offer at least one
such novelty installment: the fourth episode
of the season, airing on October 30th, marks
the show's first ever Halloween-themed chapter.
Aguirre-Sacasa mentioned it during the show's
Comic-Con panel, saying,
"We've got a really fun, spooky episode for
everyone...I know what Archie's gonna be dressed
as, and we're trying to get clearance on some
DC comic book characters."
Considering that Riverdale shares a network
with DC's "Arrowverse" shows, we may be in
for some tongue-in-cheek superhero-related
Halloween fun.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.